- What a day, what a day, what a
day, what a day!
- C'est un voyage dont il rêvait
depuis toujours et qui marque
un jalon important.
- Richard Branson a passé
quelques minutes dans l'espace,
17 ans après la création de sa
compagnie, Virgin Galactic.
Le milliardaire s'est envolé
vers 10 h 40 depuis la base
de Spaceport au Nouveau-Mexique,
accompagné de trois autres
passagers et de deux pilotes.
À quelques kilomètres de haut,
le vaisseau s'est détaché
de son avion porteur
et a poursuivi son ascension
vers l'espace.
Avant de descendre,
les passagers ont pu flotter
en apesanteur et admirer
la Terre quelques instants.
L'objectif de Richard Branson
avec ce vol d'essai : tester
et évaluer l'expérience
de ses futurs clients.
Virgin Galactic vise 2022
pour le début de ses vols
commerciaux, mais avec les prix
qui varient entre
250 et 500 000 $ le billet,
l'aventure ne s'adressera
qu'aux plus privilégiés.
Néanmoins, pour l'accompagner,
le tourisme spatial tourne une
page de son histoire.
Richard Branson devance ainsi
deux autres milliardaires dans
la course au tourisme spatial :
Jeff Bezos et Elon Musk, qui ont
lancé eux aussi leur propre
société spatiale.
L'homme le plus riche
de la planète doit s'envoler
dans neuf jours, alors que la
fusée d'Elon Musk décollera
en septembre.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, M